welcome to this video playing I ender
probably I don't know how to really
pronounce that what do we get oh and
Tiger wound fault should that thrive
galit let's play this I have some very
boring lines here okay this is not so
boring he probably didn't expect Quincy
3 and here like has some issues with
this coordination not easy to play for
black really wow ok maybe maybe
intensify pressure here on e6
Queen e7 nope that's that's running into
D 45 and then things like that okay now
maybe once so Quinn be six or something
no 25 [ __ ] just go d5 and maybe queen
no cream before FB 52 that's okay I
don't want to trade Queens down maybe I
cannot avoid it now that wasn't that
wasn't really well played by oh my me
queen before something that at least
lets him survive Bishop key to is still
quite okay for a while but I mean this
f6 and so on this is a little bit a
little bit too much should be punished
but I didn't manage to do that i really
wonder why is not playing Queen to
perform it really looks like almost the
only move I'm threatening Bishop f7
Bishop g6 as well then maybe ask some
way to defend against it but but I don't
see he's not playing Queen before I
don't know why
you're okay so I just develop stuff here
and see how it's going to try to defend
this look you want or non castles I hope
your mom ya book t1 is good so Bishop g8
or is this is this too crazy no it is
winning them I guess can go to jail for
maybe now it's not mattering I can also
go here I can also go here Bishop to b6
there should be six or is there
checkmate somewhere already and I guess
not
ok
I should have canceled long if this was
this was stronger quite quite obviously
know now that we see what happened
afterwards okay so cannot give the check
here
yeah okay it's not that this wasn't an
ideal development but still black it's
in a terrible position that it's not
like I am worse or something ship here I
guess there's something more powerful
man that's enough I could have taken c6
was check oh I should calculate
sometimes at least okay okay it's there
something something like my deaf five I
will take it
yeah come on let's let's get everything
into play they are probably some false
twins but I simply don't see them I just
just don't see a first win now the night
f5 at some point after everything is
protected and so on maybe you should
casts a long mean it's probably no
direct win after long castles
one night and night to see 50 certainly
certainly good now let's no need to to
rush things here this is some very very
bad long-term even if I have spoiled
some some wins before 20 to consume one
yeah the time is an issue I am I have
wasted lots of time him
time morning takes and takes and rook
these six probably
check check check where's the mid Bishop
b5 you there is no made right don't see
a jury I'm just I'm just just not seeing
it check and he had no way to defend
this but i was thinking there should be
some forced made black resign yeah it
was him i miss probably liked it 1010
first wins or something here the
position is just so bad yeah i mean
quincy 6 of course it was very obvious a
tear yeah i mean it all keeps keeps the
winning advantage black is just in so
bad shape that yeah it's always plus 4
and so on so probably probably it was
okay being relatively safe in the Blitz
game check Quinn chessex where's the
made a queen e 651 yeah quick e6 I
didn't see nothing but this is also made
it's also made in fact check yeah this
is the whole opening line here is quite
interesting I mean the night takes 23 is
really just bad he has to go to be 6 and
after d4 we have a normal normal line
but album but the captures is not good
here black ass in huge trouble
just one thing why didn't you play the
check your has to check his check and
after this I mean why it is probably a
bit better but this is no way as bad as
what happened in the game yeah okay I
hope you enjoyed this thanks for
watching